this is we are bringing you this
information because it is
how would you feel about this give I'm
off on holiday see you later God bless
America home of the free money San
Francisco considers reparations plan in
which five million dollars would be
given to Black residents who identify as
black supporters of the plan say it is
needed to redress the legacy of U.S
slavery and racist policies qualifying
qualifying criteria under the plan
include that a person would need to be
at least 18 years old and this is the
best bit and have identified as black or
African-American in public documents for
at least a decade so you could even if
you've been faking it long enough you
can get reparation this is in
highly mental so you could be
gone in yep and I've moved to San
Francisco because I know you work in
tech let's say you work in Tech you work
for micro whatever or Google whatever
else you're a software engineer you're
Highly Educated you're ivy league
graduate and you and you and you've
identified as black for the last 10
years before that you know what I mean
you're you're Chinese but yeah you know
because you fancied a bit of it the
food's better yeah and uh and now but
now you're black yep and uh you get five
million knicker yeah it's great and
imagine you're a Chinese guy who's also
a software developer at the same company
yeah you never had any slaves no I've
never had any family who earned any
slaves no and it's your taxes paying
your colleague five million dollars
and that ladies and gentlemen is
fairness and equality and justice that
is insane what about other people who
grow up in getting incredibly poor parts
of the United States yeah what's their
skin color
I mean why him they're white
what about Latina him
they're brown mate do you know do you
ever read like a newspaper article of
any kind then just think why is there
nowhere in this where it says this is
we are bringing you this
information because it is just
be aware as a matter of public service
and public record we would like to make
you aware that this is let me
ask you a question yeah imagine you were
black yeah how would you feel about this
oh it'd be brilliant man five
million nickel bush
someone just stunk five million dollars
in my account just because I was blank I
mean America is the land of the free
thank you very much mate
God Bless America home of the free money
yeah this ideology is do you
know the economic impact of that on on
the local housing market and everything
else would be insane house prices would
shoot up because you've got these people
who've got a ton of money now if
unless they gave them the houses for a
dollar as well as well as the five
million if they do do it I'm actually
going to accept that this is all a
simulation
how can you do that that is the most
thing I've ever heard it will
be I I almost want them to do it because
I want to see what happens I I would
actually be very curious imagine you
were 18 and someone just dumped five
million dollars no no imagine you're
homeless yeah you spend every day yeah
smoking meth yeah right and Fentanyl
yeah off your nuts you're mentally ill
to yeah and someone's just given
you five million dollars I mean that is
a reality show in the making right there
absolutely who would not want to follow
a few homeless people with five million
dollars and serious mental illness
I mean that would be incredible
entertainment
I look it's worth it
I want to see a guy with no teeth and
five million dollars yeah have at it hey
click it'll be worth it yeah it's a bit
of a high budget operation yeah but it'd
be worth it walking to Gucci while
seeing his dead ancestors around him
I'll take the leather trousers yeah
mine insane all right Anton let's find
out what the beautiful bigots are saying
in the chat about this story and other